hey what is up guys mkbhd here back with
a quick video that i wasn't expecting to
make on something that came out today
from samsung's announcements this phone
you're looking at here kind of looks a
lot like a galaxy note 4. i just did an
impressions video on one you might not
be able to tell the difference
except that it's totally weird
this is the thing now this is the
samsung galaxy note edge and yes this is
absolutely another one of samsung's
crazy let's try everything phones that's
actually coming to life
and to be fair when the galaxy note
first came out it was another crazy
experiment but now they're everywhere so
maybe this is one of those things that
looks crazy now but you know might look
totally normal in the future who knows
so this is the note edge it's clearly
nearly identical to the galaxy note 4
it's brother it has all the same
internal specs all the same software
same camera same everything but it has
some extra display hanging off the edge
and that's what they call it the edge
display or the edge screen so here's how
it works up front on the front is a 5.6
inch quad hd super amoled display it's
fantastic so again super high pixel
density here and then curved over on the
right hand side is an additional 160
pixel wide strip of display and that's
it that's what this phone is all about i
figured i'd show it to you guys because
you're probably going to start hearing
about it on the news as samsung's crazy
new curved display
but it's really not all that crazy it
already has the super high-end specs
that we know are going to perform well
from the note 4 so it's really all about
whether or not this awkward shape can
actually help using the phone instead of
hurting it so samsung's built in a bunch
of different features into the software
to work just on that strip that you can
swipe between there's sports cores
custom messages twitter trending topics
even an alarm clock mode that'll just
show the time super dim but what's
really cool or at least what can make
this really cool is that samsung is
giving out an sdk for developers to be
able to make apps that actually use this
strip it's called the edge screen
there's already a bunch of settings and
a bunch of things to pick from but the
other thing people aren't talking about
is when you really want to take
advantage of that entire front display
that strip needs to get out the way and
when i spend time with it it looks like
it does a pretty decent job of doing so
so like when i'm watching a youtube
video and i go full screen the bar
disappears so it's fine it leaves this
faint text that says my galaxy note edge
but i think it should really be just
pitch black and then when i want to
bring it back i can swipe in at any time
move around between them and when i want
to go full screen again i can just tap
the video again and it goes back to full
screen so as long as it's this seamless
it seems like it will be out of my way
when i don't want it
and it's actually kind of hard to tell
where the flat part of the screen ends
and the curved part begins because the
graphics overlap so often but i could
see this kind of stuff being useful to
someone once they get used to the
swiping gestures to bring these tools in
and out of view
there will always be people saying
that's really dumb i'm never going to
use that but again some people will
probably be willing to try it i think
the one thing they drew up pretty well
is these quick tools which are a swipe
down from the side and they provide this
quick access anywhere to tools like a
stopwatch a voice recorder or even a
ruler and what makes them so great is
they operate entirely in the side panel
so they're not like a window hovering
over the top of your main activity this
is true multitasking because they're
just over the side next to what you're
doing they're not interrupting that's
pretty legit
also it left me wondering a couple
things like which hand am i supposed to
use this in are lefty is not supposed to
use this am i crazy
for thinking this actually looks kind of
cool i don't know i figured i would show
it to you guys it's obviously a bit of a
weird experiment but something i felt
the need to get on video if you're into
the note 4 this is something that's
literally going to show up in stores
alongside the note 4 when it comes out
the only difference is going to be the
edge screen and the slightly smaller
3000 milliamp hour battery since the
curve kind of takes away some space but
honestly the one that's going to decide
whether or not this succeeds or fails is
you because it's again it's another one
of those samsung throw it out the wall
see if it sticks experiments so what do
you think even after just watching
videos on it i honestly don't know how i
feel i held one i messed around with one
i still don't know how i feel obviously
it has a lot of the same advantages of
the note 4 with the s pen the camera
huge display aluminum but on the other
hand it still seems really awkward and
unnecessary and cumbersome but that was
only after an hour of use so let me know
your thoughts the comment section right
below that like button is always open
thanks for watching this quick one and
stay tuned for the next because
september is just getting started talk
to you guys later peace